l'équipe du cabaret du bout des prêts
près de cerner la ville a retrouvé le
chemin de la scène enfants après une
longue période d'absence ceux liés à la
situation sanitaire forcément la
nouvelle saison est donc lancée c'est
justin qui nous parle de sa
programmation exactement et pour cette
nouvelle saison wilfried le kabary va
tourner autour de deux spectacles phares
je vous le disais donc une nouveauté 1
et puis le spectacle déjà dix ans
pourquoi déjà 10 ans et parce que le
cabaret fait justement ses 10 ans en
tout cas devait fêter l'année dernière
mais il a été repoussé en raison de la
crise sanitaire il y aura les meilleurs
tableaux des spectacles précédents et
voilà donc on pourra le découvrir cette
année mais ce n'est pas réservé aux
classes et vous nous en dit un peu plus
sur ce nouveau spectacle donc l'autre le
nouveau spectacle à l'affiché cabaret
quatre saisons c'est une comédie
musicale sur le thème du cabaret des
années 60 sur scène il y aura une
dizaine d'artistes pour vous en mettre
plein les yeux danseurs chanteurs et
comédiens le responsable du cabaret nous
en dit plus au micro de mélanie poquet
[Musique]
laissez vous tenter c'est un roman chez
soi où l'on veut
chanter des arrivées reda
tu sois gloriette
c'est l'histoire d'un amas pizzaïolo eux
qui est installée juste à côté d'un
cabaret et qui tombe amoureux de la
meneuse de revue du cabaret d'à côté est
ce qu'on ne sait pas c'est que ce
pizzaiolos l'histoire se passe dans les
années 60 et ce pizzaïolo en fait a
toujours dit qu'il offrirait une
nouvelle pizza à celle qu'il aime et
s'avère que cette pizza c'est de là
quatre saisons qui n'existaient pas
madame croissance et donc c'est lui le
créateur de la pizza cassé
et en plateau la chorégraphie a été
plutôt apprécié justin setaf
voilà vous avez tout à fait le rythme
pendant la séquence les gens ne voient
pas tout mais ils doivent tous savoir
quels sont les changements principaux de
ce nouveau spectacle alors il ya eu
plusieurs changements notamment le kabar
a profité de cette période de crise
sanitaire pour refaire des travaux
revend l'intérieur remettent leurs
pattes vous le verrez notamment le
rideau et la scène et les coulisses ont
été changés la moquette et passer du
rouge au violet le rideau est passé d'un
rouge au violet ce tracé
voilà et puis un peu de travaux dans les
murs un peu tout un pot de peinture
comme dans la loge que vous pouvez voir
juste derrière voilà qui mêle à des
paillettes dans ses murs pour cette
nouvelle année 80 dates sont prévues sur
l'ensemble de l'année donc des
spectacles la moitié sont déjà réservées
en règle générale il ya dix mille
spectateurs par an informations et
réservations sur le site du cabaret du
bout des prix